i had previously been in a five-year
relationship an eight-year relationship
and then an on and off again
nearly three-year relationship um still
lightly
talking to the guy and um i am somebody
i enjoy being feminine
i love doting on men um
he didn't really like that and i just
i don't know i guess what's what's your
advice because
i think you know eventually i'm as i
said i'm working on myself right now
and eventually i i would like to have
that exclusive ltr
um not really worried about having kids
at all
marriage is not really a thing i'm
worried about either just would like to
have somebody that
um where we compliment each other like
you say i have read your book
and i believe it to a t i
actually was telling men the other day
that they should look it up and so um
i just you know i want to know how to be
that feminine woman where
i can be doting on a man and he doesn't
feel i don't know i don't even know how
he felt
because he he's a little bit of a black
pill how old are you
35 and you were dating a black pill guy
yeah so he um
he unfortunately had a horrific divorce
and i just i wanted to come into his
world and
into his frame and be that kind of woman
who could be different from the rest
um because he shared with me how the
other women had been
and i i know that him and i have a
different type of relationship than he's
had with other women
and i just you know i just want to be a
quality woman to somebody
and i'm just not really sure where to go
from here and if you have any advice
in terms of like that dating and how to
become a better woman
um working on the red flags that i
identify with in your book
so um just wanted to try the red flags
that you identified with
so unfortunately and this is where i'm
starting
you know to work on taking
responsibility um
in my very early 20s i put myself
in some situations where things ended up
happening that
i wouldn't have desired to happen and
i did take on a victim mentality because
i was terrified for the longest time
and so i'm now like okay
i was responsible for putting myself in
that situation i shouldn't have done
that
and i just gave me a little more clarity
on what the situation was because it's
pretty vague right now um i
mean you're totally anonymous aside from
your first name but so i had
um i i was roofied more than once
okay so partying like uh raves
nightclubs stuff like that
so it it how it started out was the
five-year relationship was
and i hate this term but it was a high
school sweetheart
and i had this fantasy world that i was
going to be with one man my entire life
and that's what i you know i wanted to
i've always wanted to be a doting woman
and when he wanted to end the
relationship
i tried to fill a void by going out with
friends
and put myself in some you know
dangerous situations that i
i look back on and and i'm ashamed about
but now the only thing i can do is move
forward and
try to become a better person okay so
um i mean first of all you want to stay
away from anybody with a victim mindset
like
the toxic feminist narrative is a victim
mindset that men should avoid
there's men that behave the same way
where they have the victim mindset right
um oh you know all women are horrible
they're brutal they're all gonna
you know like take advantage of you take
all your and then dump you and go
and bang chat
um okay well that's hypergamy kind of
you know defined in their own way but at
the end of the day
like if you're on your purpose if you've
got options if
um if you're putting yourself first
stuff like that doesn't really cross a
man's mind right so
just stay away from anybody with a
victim mindset you can't win at life
with a victim mindset so
that's the first thing um where do you
live like what part of the country
so this is the downfall is i am actually
very close to
washington d.c and i have
yes and i have had to cut out a
large volume of women from my life
and then of course limit some family
interactions
because my values just don't align with
the women here
okay so can you move can you go
somewhere else
so that's something that i've been you
know looking into
some um there are some areas that i'm
interested in
and just it's kind of going in the way
of
what's going to work out professionally
um in terms of where i can land
so so that's kind of what's a little bit
holding me back at the moment
but i would like to be in an area where
where a feminine woman is
the i guess you could say the norm
because it's
it's not yeah right so that would be
your first
um step would be to basically move
to a target rich environment um
like i would tell guys not to live in
washington dc if they could avoid it
right because there's
they don't have a lot of choices when it
comes to feminine you know
more conservative type of women over
there that are gonna
um respond well to a top shelf guy
that's an alpha male it's unplugged from
the bs lies and all that sort of stuff
so
move to a more target rich environment
would be the first thing the second
thing is i mean if you're working on
your red flags awesome make sure that
you know you get those out of the way
but um yeah like guys with victim
mindsets are a big no-no um
what age range are you dating in so i
will say
i had been dating at a younger age range
and i was experiencing something that um
my other friends weren't when i was you
know out
looking and i was experiencing men
who were putting pressure on me about
marriage and children and it was making
me feel
uncomfortable because i've just i've
always been on the fence for
you're 35 what age range have you been
dating in though so
the the one that's been on and off three
year
he is um three and a half years younger
than me
okay so early thirties he's early
thirties i'm mid thirties
um but i am thinking you know when i
am ready to get back out there i would
ideally like to look at men in their
40s yeah i mean ideally you probably
want to go about 10 years older than you
is what i would say like 40s 45
you find lots of guys that are well put
together you might have some guys that
have been through the divorce grinder
that it might have some kids in tow and
a little bit of baggage but
i mean if they've got their head screwed
on right and um you know they're doing
the work they'll
they'll be fine like you don't have any
kids i have no kids
i just have nieces and i
like and prefer to be an aunt yeah okay
so
like you're kind of a unicorn there's a
lot there's not a lot of women your age
um that kind of had their head you know
head screwed on right that are
you know clear on what the end goal is
stick to that
you know and just just put yourself out
there but ideally
your best bet is going to be to move to
a more target rich environment
if you want to hunt deer go to where the
deer are at you're not going to find
or sorry it's going to be unlikely that
you're going to find the kind of guy
that you're looking for where you live
so a big part of fixing this is moving
to
where you've got a better environment
that's going to facilitate that
um and if like i wouldn't date guys
younger than you like
generally speaking when younger men date
older women
and there's not a huge age difference
you know between i don't know 33 and 35
or whatever
but i mean you get the idea like
relationships tend to work out better
when when the age range difference is
of course in the favor of the guy which
believe it or not at the end of the day
works out for the women too i mean
there's a lot of guys out there that are
still well put together in the 40s
and you're going to hate hearing it but
guys
you know age like a fine wine and women
tend to age like milk but
yeah that's the reality of men and women
it's it's just a fact so
just get yourself out there and just
start doing it right and and just one
other thing so
in my 20s um i think i did something
that
a lot of women do and i
um i didn't just try to fill a void by
dating the wrong men but i also tried to
fill a void by
spending money that i shouldn't be
spending and so now in my 30s i'm
you know heavily working on reversing
that
and as somebody from a financial
background
what would you recommend there as well
how much debt do you have
much more than i want to admit exactly i
need a number 60
60k okay is it student debt or is it
unsecured debt um so it is
about one-third student debt i have a
10k car and then the rest was
consolidated from
my um poor choices in my youth
okay do you have a big notch count
uh around 20 okay well that's going to
come back to haunt you at some point if
a smart guy catches you know catches
wind on that so
make sure you're not riding the carousel
still as far as the debt goes
the um the 60 like
60 grand if you've got student debt
you're going to have to pay it off
as far as i'm aware in the u.s there's
no real plan that lets you settle it or
go insolvent with it or anything like
that and it doesn't sound like
you're having a hard time managing it it
just has
what you're telling is you have a hard
time paying it off right so you're not
really paying the balance down you're
carrying it month after month
so i right now um i have it in a loan
form
and i try to pay more each month than
what is actually due
well debt is a math problem
you know so it's it's spend spend less
than what you make and then just apply
you know disposable income towards that
so if you've got preferences in life
uh that you're gonna need to set aside
i'm just i'm just gonna go with the
standard stuff so you're gonna have to
forgive me handbag
shoes you know the standard crap um set
it aside minimize your expenses
and throw as much as you can at the debt
problem uh tackle
tackle whatever you can to at least get
some wins you know
um if you've got unsecured debt like are
you a property owner do you have a house
or condo or anything
no i'm a renter okay so do you have
any assets to your nick uh
i would say no because my car i still
owe one so
so your value kind of goes up and down
elizabeth
it's like doesn't have any kids in tow
from prior marriages and a bunch of
dudes
kind of has a bit of a notch count and
some debt nothing to her name
so like these are all things that guys
are going to be paying attention to
right so
of course you know fix what you can
forget about what you can and just move
forward
the debt issue can be dealt with you
might want to talk to
um a buddy of mine runs a uh company
in the us called uh
freedomdebtrelief.com
um it's big they've been around for a
long time they basically do what my
company does in canada but they're
licensed
and set up to work in the us and they
can settle at
unsecured debt quite quickly they're
fully legit so you don't have to have
you like worry about is this a scam it's
legit so see if that
works for you you can inquire with them
but the student debt you're gonna have
to take care of on your own maybe
that'll speed things up for you but
i mean by a certain age guys if you're
going to date guys in their 40s
they're not really going to want to deal
with debt issues or
a lot of baggage especially if they're
properly put together which is the kind
of guy that you're looking for so
there's a few other things that you can
work
on in your court once you've got those
out of the way or fix as best as you can
your value will look a little more
attractive to
men but the most important thing for you
is get the hell out of dc and go
somewhere
you know where the environment's more
favorable to facilitate what is it
you're looking for because your options
are going to be pretty low where you're
at
yeah and and that's why i i as i said
i'm not like looking to go out
right now and meet people i really just
want to work on myself so that
when i do feel ready for that i i want
to bring the best version of me to
to a man right but don't but don't
ignore that
like your value like your beauty uh
it's it's expiration date gets closer
and close closer year after year so
if you're sitting out of the sexual
marketplace for five years dealing with
all this in no time you're going to
be 40
you're not going to be as attractive as
you are today right so
you know put yourself out there but be
selective with the time that you spent
no i i appreciate your feedback yeah no
i appreciate it um i think that there's
a lot of women out there who could
actually use
listening to your channel and and thank
you so much for your time
you got it thanks alright take care okay
ciao
you